where is your next client going to come
from it's wild to me how much joy
anxiety happiness and panic can come
from six simple words I'd even go as far
as saying that that single question can
make or break an entrepreneurs marriage
so while there's many places where
clients can OB obviously come from and
in my opinion the terms
predictability control and consistency
so many of us are looking for are really
just Illusions used by marketers to sell
more of their Solutions so I really only
know one thing which is my life got a
lot easier when I got about 2 to three
leads every single day that are asking
about my services so over the last 6
months I've been paying lead generators
about $20 a day to send quality intent
leads directly into my inbox and today I
want to share with you how I did that so
everything from setting the whole thing
up finding those lead generators and
turning the leads that they send into
actual clients and the way we're going
about that is that first I'll share with
you what Le generators are those are
actually humans not some AI what they
use to identify your best prospects and
then actually convert them into quality
leads asking for your services will go
through all of my scripts Sops and all
that we're using that actually turns
those prospects first into followers and
email subscribers then into quality
leads again that are asking for my
services as well as all the kpis so you
know if it is for you or not so a minute
ago I told you that there's many
different places where clients can come
from one can run ads one can build an
audience on social media one can become
a great writer there's many different
ways and where clients can come from and
while I do most of those things inside
my business here's why lead generator is
really being a game changer for the
Consulting business that I'm running one
I don't really need to write any AD copy
I don't need to set up funnels or or
really any automation or any Tech so it
is very simple for me to get going and
get results very quickly then number two
it comes closest to what people call
predictable no matter if I'm on vacation
no matter if I work a lot no matter if I
work very little over the last 6 months
I've been getting those two to three
leads almost every single day and the
leads that I've been getting they are of
super superior quality meaning we're
actually converting those leads into 15
16k Consulting gigs directly into the
DMS without sales calls and even a
friend of mine Scott thean he just
recently converted one of the leads into
an 80k a year contract with a TMS
practice so the leads are of superior
quality too and then last but not least
I can pay the lead generators on
performance meaning when I need more
leads I can pay them more and when I
need less leads I can pay them less
there's one caveat so I really only need
about two to three leads every single
day if one needs a 100 leads every
single day lead generators might not be
the best solution for you and I would
recommend to maybe run ads and funnels
to get there speaking of who Le
generators are for and who I would
probably not recommend them to there's
really two types of coaches Consultants
uh course creators and henc owners that
we've successfully tested lead
generators W so let me run through those
two types really quick one are the ones
who just validated a brand new offer
meaning you have an offer you may be
sold two or three of those and you have
proof that the offer is working so for
you to get that offer to 10 K you really
just need more eyeballs more leads the
generators are great for them because
obviously you just signed a couple
clients so you got to deliver on a
fairly new offer while still selling and
marketing yourself to continuously get
clients I believe lead generators to be
great for you because it alleviates a
lot of pressure meaning you can
continuously get more clients without
working more hour or sacrificing the
quality of results you're going to
deliver to your new clients then type
number two are really the solo Founders
who are already making 10K a month or
more but are at this weird place where
they're juggling too many plates at once
and everything they do is working but to
get that offer to 50K a month they
really just need more time and leverage
to get there Le generators are great for
them because instead of chasing Elites
they can focus on converting Elites and
buyback time of a sales process
especially doing sales calls that is
already time consuming and for most of
those solo Founders ads would work too
but many are not really in a position
where they a have the time or the funds
to go out there and build funnels build
automations build pages and dump maybe
$50 $200 a day into ads to really get an
appropriate amount of data and leads to
make that worthwhile so lead generators
are great for them to get lead sent to
them get that automation going get
clients on autopilot and really start
getting ready for running ads cool so if
one of those is you or you're just
curious then let's actually go through
that breakdown and jump over to my
computer great you're still here so
let's dive into the breakdown what are
lead generators so lead generators are
simply affordable humans trained on two
things using social media and databases
like Apollo to actually identify your
dream prospects in the first place so
they follow your criteria whatever you
feel like your best prospects are and
search the interwebs and the social
medias to identify those individuals and
they then turn those prospects first
into followers and email subscribers and
then into qualified leads excited and
primed to learn about your offer so one
of the Le generators I'm using who's now
working full-time for my business is
Calvin Ando he operates on performance
meaning he gets paid based on how many
qualified prospects he identifies and
contacts now I I pay him on average
anywhere between $10 to $20 a day you
can either recruit lead generators who
have experience or train them up
yourself I've done both and both Works
fantastically well at the end of the day
what it really comes down to is being
able to equip your lead generators with
the right software and proven assets so
they can actually use your so seon and
run the process smoothly so now that we
understand what lead generators are
what's the actual setup that they need
to operate every single day and get you
leads that are excited to speak about
your offer so internally we are using a
software called flow chat but Le
generators can easily be trained on
simple Google Sheets or use complicated
things like Salesforce since we're using
flow chat I'll quickly show you what
that is now float is one using
automations to quickly scrape leads from
social media so let's say Brad I just
found him um let's assume that people
who are engaging with his content could
be Irrelevant for what I'm using or
could have some dream prospects inside
it we can essentially go ahead and click
one of those buttons to import all of
those
1,441 likes engagements Etc SE them into
Naomi is another um lead generator SE
them into the pipeline into the stage
right here import a prospect and then
number two it can essentially run an AI
to go through those profiles that we
sapped and identify the individuals and
the businesses and the profiles that
have intent for what you are selling so
flowchart is owned by friends of mine
it's usually
$247 a month I think but I still have
some links left there you can actually
get it for $97 a month for a lifetime so
now that your Elite generators
essentially have filled their Pipeline
with prospects how do they now go ahead
and turn them into followers email
subscribers and then into leads who are
asking about your services internally we
essentially use a two-part process one
part are the audience growth messages to
contact the prospect turn them into
followers and email subscribers and then
conversion messages to essentially get
them to ask us about our services I feel
like the best way for me to show you
that is to just actually look into my
inbox I have my leite generators use my
profiles because I trust them when they
started they use their own ones but um
essentially just looking at some of
those conversations let's look at em so
um that here is a classic audience
growth message where essentially the
lead generators have a highly
personalized script where they
personalize the message to the
individual they're reaching out to lead
with value and we generally not always
but get responses like these of people
excited and grateful and then
essentially we internally we're asking
for their emails we get the email and in
exchange we're then sharing I guess what
people would call a lead magnet so
here's what that lead magnet looks like
that lead magnet is essentially again
the lead generator personalizes it and
it follows a template it's the same lead
magnet we sent to everyone besides
obviously the personalization you can
see here which runs people through our
unique mechanism which is basically the
lead sniper system that we're using here
now it runs them through it now we sell
directly by Chad so it tells people
about an offer most of the people that
are using Le generators would generally
go to a sales conversation which is fine
too but then ultimately that is sent and
here we actually get Emil just today
reaching out and asking for my offer and
asking for my next steps again we sell
by Chad but um that would be a great
point to again just I guess uh book of
sales conversation so that's the
two-part process we're using there is an
audience growth message to essentially
lead with value and turn prospects into
followers and email subscribers and then
it can conversion message to get them to
ask about our services that's pretty
much it all right so let's speak about
actual kpis and what to expect now in my
experience a lead generator can very
easily identify 200 dream prospects and
can contact those 200 every single week
they could even do more but if you are
just using social media like let's say
just LinkedIn then usually you can you
can't really do more than 200 because
it's a limitation from the platform per
profile that you are running so if you
are measuring with 200 individual
contacts then this is what you can
expect out of 200 prospects contacted
you can expect on the low end at least
20 followers and email subscribers and
on the high end 50 um email subscribers
and followers out of those 2250 you will
get on the lowend 14 leads asking for
your services and on the high end about
21 now if you do any marketing outside
of that outside of using lead generators
you might be sending emails you might be
posting content then you can naturally
capture an order 20 to 30% within 30 60
90 days just based on your other
marketing efforts okay so you have two
options option one go out there yourself
find the rightly generate aters create
the scripts create the templates create
the offers eventually crack the code to
get 223 leads sent to you by lead
generators you're absolutely capable to
do that I have no single out that you
can crack that code eventually question
is if you have the time and for how much
longer you want to worry about where
your next client is going to come from
so if enough is enough then I want to
make you an offer where you can install
Le generator inside your business get
your first two or three quality intent
leads within like the next 48 to 72
hours for
$17 all right so on the page you're on
right now you can secure the Le
generator course for just $17 usually
sold at $200 if you scroll down you get
to see what's included essentially
you're going to get the complete
stepbystep course of how my lead
generator system works and how to get
three quality intent leads begging to
work with me every single day and how
you can get them to in again 48 to 72
hours fled I'll also going to show you
how for $20 lead generators will drop
those leads directly into your inbox and
grow your email list with seven or more
hyper targeted subscribers every single
day you'll also get the exct scripts
lead magnets templates Miley generators
use to send me email subscribers and
leads who want to work with me so you
can swipe those and and can get going
incredibly quickly you'll also get as a
bonus my proven messenger ready offer
templates for you to swipe so if you're
looking to sell by chat without sales
calls this is going to show you how and
how to launch such an offer within 24
hours or less you're also going to get
my entire Tech deack to manage leads
track lead generators and the AI I'm
using to turn leads into clients on
autopilot it's literally the whole
enchilada to get your first three leads
in 72 hours and then every single day
everything you need to imp to implement
this inside your business is waiting for
you inside the lead generator course
which you can get for $17 today I hope
you're picking this up